there's a lot in this scene at the
Vatican that would have looked exactly
the same hundreds of years ago but some
centuries-old traditions if the Roman
Catholic Church could be about to change
of course okay ketta format there are
some things to reform the church always
has to reform itself Pope Francis has
been hosting bishops nuns and community
leaders from the Amazon to discuss
challenges such as the destruction of
the rainforest but the most hotly
debated question was whether to allow
some married men to join the priesthood
and remote locations where there aren't
enough clergy to perform regular mass
the majority of the bishops also called
for the Vatican to look into whether
women should be ordained as deacons a
role currently reserved for lay men who
are allowed to preach baptized witness
marriages and perform funerals the Pope
admitted the church had yet to grasp the
significance of women you know what I
mean this was a very we need to
underline this we do not realize the
role of women in the church we just look
at the functional part which is
important but the role of women in the
church goes far beyond functionality the
group is urging the church to recognize
the unique spirituality cultures and
needs of the Amazonian faithful but it
could have repercussions beyond this
isolated territory some conservatives
have warned that allowing such
exceptions could lead the global
Catholic Church to ruin is opening the
question if it's more important to
preserve the celibacy requirement at the
cost of having many communities without
a priest for many many months every year
anger over the mere discussion of the
proposal saw some Amazonian statues
stolen from a church during the meeting
and tossed into the Tiber River though
they were later recovered undamaged Pope
Francis will consider the
recommendations and report back by the
end of the year but in a signal women
have some way to go in the church while
they could offer opinions on the ideas
during the assembly they weren't allowed
to cast a vote
Alexia O'Brien al Jazeera